the truth is about to come out and a lot of
Wellness influencers are gonna be [Music]
mad hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome back
to my channel let's ruffle some misinformed
Wellness influencers feathers so there is
no shortage of Miss and disinformation on
social media right now largely perpetuated
by content creators with huge platforms and
zero education or training in the field
so I thought we would play a little game
called let's make Wellness influencers who
are profiting off of pseudo science super
duper mad by breaking down the science also
don't forget to hit up my description I've
got a free Hunger crushing combo ebook with lots
of great ideas for building balanced meals and
snacks and also please subscribe if you have
not already there is a lot more where this
came from okay folks controversial claim not
number one drinking diet coke causes cancer an
ingredient found in drinks like Diet Coke could
have the potential to be cancerous according to
scientists still don't love it so recently the
ho came out with a recategorization of aspartame
as a carcinogen which the media interpreted
as Diet Coke causing cancer but this feels to
understand what the data and classification system
actually mean so Tobacco For example is a group
one carcinogen which means that it's carcinog to
humans similar to alcohol and asbestos red meat
appears in group 2A along with air pollution and
shift work which means that it's probably carcinus
and yes I said shift work and then aspartame falls
into group 2B AKA possibly carcinogenic to humans
in case you're wondering what else is classified
in group 2B like aspartame consider things like
aloe vera pickled vegetables progesterone
only contraceptives and electromagnetic
fields which your cell phones emit around you
all day now in order for aspartam to meet the
criteria for 2B there has to be limited evidence
of Cancer Association in humans and insufficient
experimental evidence in animals or if there's
no human evidence at all there has to be enough
evidence that there is a mechanism in animals
that could potentially apply to humans in other
words it is far from causation what makes this
classification even more confusing and some ways
kind of useless is that it just tells you about
the strength of the evidence not how risky it is
in real life or how much of the substance would
be needed to actually cause harm all of these
substances are basically just lumped into one
category as if spending your entire life breathing
an ashal is the same as having an occasional can
of Diet Coke we may see updated recommendations in
the future but right now the FDA has suggested
that a daily intake of 50 Mig per kilogram of
body weight or like 19 cans of diet coca day
would be under the safe amount so friends the
dose makes the poison I don't personally drink
diet coke as you can see it's not my vibe but
I think you should treat aspartame like sugar and
enjoy it in moderation it's not a health food but
it's probably not going to be the primary reason
for anyone's decline moving on to a cookie but a
goodie a six-pack is a healthy goal for all women
okay I'm going to tell you guys how I got abs um
here are my credentials um I feel like a lot of
people over complicate it and it's really very
simple this one will definitely make the fitness
influencer girlies mad because spoiler alert it's
not and here's the thing some women naturally have
more visible abs without having to put themselves
through an outrageously restrictive diet or ere
ex exercising protocol and hormonally they may
appear completely healthy but the vast majority
of us women are just not meant to be that lean to
see visible abde definition like a tight sixpack
most women need to get down to 14 to 20% body fat
and yet most of us need around 26 to 28% body
fat to regulate our cycle reproductive hormones
and support natural fertility again bodies come
in all different shapes and sizes and there are
a lot of women who can maintain low body fat
percentages have a six-pack and still get a
period ovulate and get pregnant but typically the
behaviors taken to get said six-pack AKA extreme
chloric restriction OV exercising or both with or
without a low body fat percentage are also huge
risk factors for an ovulation a menorrhea and
hormonal irregularities so despite what social
media may make you believe a six-pack should
not be the goal this one's really going to push
some people's buttons but if it's part of the
dirty dozen you absolutely must biorganic ewg
just released their 2023 list of the dirty dozen
in Clean 15 if Bob's talking about it you know
I'm going to have something to say so the dirty
dozen is a list that's released annually by the
egw or the environmental working group where they
list the fruits and vegetables with the greatest
pesticide residues if you haven't heard of the
ewg lucky you but in short they Market themselves
as being these unbiased truth Crusaders going
head-to-head with big food the FDA and USDA and
other major health authorities basically they rank
food products based on how clean they are loudly
opposing any conventionally grown or GMO crops and
while they are super vague about their sponsors
and donors they do list a number of organic food
brands and clean Beauty Brands which many claim
may affect how these brands are ranked without
proper disclosure transparency issues aside I
am personally a lot more concerned with some
of their dubious anti-science board members
and the fact that they have published blatant
disinformation incling including a 2004 article
linking vaccines to autism that right there should
be a big red FL so yeah I've never personally been
a fan so the way they come up with their dirty
dozen list is by looking at the pesticide data
program which samples more than 10,000 food
samples for pesticide residues their findings
actually remind us how safe our food actually
is seeing as over 99% of samples tested had
residues below the tolerances set by the EPA and
42% had no detectable pesticide residues at all
in fact the residues here are so low that we would
reach toxicity levels from the fruit or vegetable
themselves before we would reach toxicity levels
from the pesticides on them the alliance for
food and farming developed a calculator to
show you how many servings of a dirty dozen
fruit or veg you would actually need to eat in
one day to reach beyond the no adverse effects
level and here are the results you'd have to eat
almost 2,000 peaches over 2300 nectarines nearly
75 500 servings of kale 340 apples or almost 7500
servings of celery you would be sh your pants all
day for days if you ate this not because of the
pesticides but because of the fodmaps and fiber
so obviously folks the dose makes the poison now
the other issue with the dirty dozen is similar
to the issue on how carcinogens like aspartame are
classified it doesn't incorporate risk assessment
into the calculations all of the pesticides
are weighted equally and we don't factor in
the levels deemed acceptable by the EPA in other
words the list is based solely on residue count
not what the chemical is what concentration it
is in that food and how those levels compare to
the epa's tolerance levels for specific chemicals
they also never mentioned the fact that organic
foods contain pesticides too which may or may not
be safer than synthetic like anyone remember the
natural organic pesticide rotenone we thought that
was super safe because it was all natural but it
ended up attacking the mitochondria and causing
Parkinson's disease in rats my point here is not
that organic foods are also bad it's that assuming
you're not eating thousands of peaches every
single day conventional produce is absolutely safe
and fear-mongering wellness information like The
Dirty Dozen does actual harm here one study found
that fearmongering pesticide messaging resulted in
lowincome families who couldn't afford organic
produce to purchase less produce altogether we
don't need to further the health disparities in
this country with misinformation like this so
organic conventional buy whatever you can afford
and just like wash it well and speaking of produce
if you don't eat vegetables just drink ag1 here
is my everyday pickme up and breakfast that has
really helped my gut health and floating oh boy
this one's going to be spicy so I jve deep into
the claims and facts in my greens powder video
right here but in short I don't see anything wrong
with greens powders and some may be better than
others but at least as they appear on the market
today they will not replace fed vegetables are not
just like a combination of micronutrients they're
one of the best sources of dietary fiber and it's
fiber more than almost anything that most North
Americans are not getting enough of that should
be the focus of eating your green stuff not the
4 67% of your vitamin see in ag1 that you're
just going to pee out anyway interestingly a
lot of the influencers are promoting Brands like
ag1 and Bloom greens as being great for bloating
but if you legitimately suffer from bloating
and therefore have a sensitive gut a lot of
the ingredients in these powders are just going to
make things worse things like inulin fiber chory
root and fructooligosaccharides just to name a
few now there's a lot of great stuff in these
things too don't get me wrong but since these
beneficial ingredients are often and bundled
in these huge proprietary Blends we actually have
zero clue of how much you're actually getting most
of the functional ingredients listed on labels
have clinical doses of 1 to 10 G each and since
each scoop of powder is generally in the 10 to 15
G range it is highly unlikely that you're getting
clinically relevant doses of most if not all of
those ingredients you could also hypothetically
be getting dangerously high amounts of some of
these ingredients for you so just something to
keep in mind if if you want to know exactly what
you're taking bottom line I don't think that
there's anything wrong with taking greens powders
and some are better than others but think of them
as like a powdered multivitamin with flavor not a
replacement for actual fiber rich veg and finally
oats are toxic and bad for your blood sugars I've
done a couple episodes now where oatmeals come up
and I think people are starting to realize it's
not a good option it's not a good option at all
not just because of the actual oats but the
glyphosate the oatmeal heat has been Fierce
this year namely thanks to a lot of carnivore
or paleo influencers doing the podcast circuit
but let's set a few things straight here
one oats are not bad for your blood sugars
like the carnivore Clan insists how do I know
this oh hi there hugan analysis and systematic
review of the literature that found that oats
were beneficial for blood glucose control oats
actually significantly reduced A1C fasting glucose
total cholesterol LDL cholesterol acute proprial
glucose and Insulin responses now the type of
Oats will matter when it comes to satiety and
how long they'll hold you so instant oats will
cause the greatest Spike and fall while steel cut
oats will maintain blood glucose levels longer as
will what you serve with it adding protein and fat
effectively lowers the blood sugar curve and this
is all what I recommend anyways so try adding nuts
seeds high fiber berries hemp Parts flax protein
powder and milk to your o help stabilize blood
sugars and improve satiety next let's talk about
glyphosate so to start all this hysteria around
glyphosate is based on Independent opinions by
the ewg or environmental working group which as
we've established is pretty well understood to
be a dubious Source in the science Community but
let's put their findings into some context here
the epa's tolerable limit for glyphosate is 30
Perth per million the ewg found that the worst oat
of Fender contained up to 2800 ppb AKA 2.8 parts
per million based on the official EPA standards
you would have to consume over 10 servings of
conventionally grown oats a day to reach that
amount please do not do that now of course the ewg
claims the limits should be much lower which is
a totally fair belief but just like their funding
sources they're not super transparent about what
these opinions for benchmarks are based on that
said but if you're still concerned because you or
your kids eat a lot of oatmeal like mine do then
consider organic or stretch your portion by adding
in all of those blood sugar regulating ingredients
that I just shared you definitely should not give
up your oats when I make oats for myself and my
kids I typically do like 2/3 oats 1/3 hemp Parts a
ripe banana a scoop of peanut butter a little bit
of butter protein Rich milk high fiber berries
and usually some sprinkles and chocolate chips
on top obviously and trust me I am full for a
good while so obviously there are a lot more
misinformed Wellness influencer claims to unpack
here so please leave me a comment below with
whatever you want me to discuss in more detail
and I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
[Music] bye